hi here is mathias from datatab and in
this video i'd like to show you
how you can easily calculate the man
with new test
online with datatab if you want to use
your own data
you first need to clear the table
afterwards you can enter
your own data i will simply copy the
data
from the example so i copy this data
and paste it into this table
so i have two variables the reaction
time
woman and the reaction time man
in order to calculate the man with new
test i simply
click on t-test keycard r test and anova
and then select the two variables
reaction time woman and reaction time
man
now i have to choose whether i have an
independent sample
or paired sample in this case we have
independent
samples and i have to choose if i want
to calculate
a paired a parametric test or
non-parametric test
in this case we want to calculate a
non-parametric
test and now i get the results for the
men
whitney u test in this table i get the
ranks
for the two variables i get the mean
rank
and the sum of the ranks and in this
table i get the statistics for the men
with new test
so in this case i get a p-value
of 0.862 which is higher
than the p-value of 0.05
and thus and this test is not
significant
and there's no difference between
the two groups thank you for watching
this video
and if you have questions just leave me
a comment
bye